[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 y me acompaña allá en el
estudio rosa pérez más de euros a muy
buena mañana ya de martes muy bienvenida
abrimos entonces esta sección con un
pequeño repaso por las portadas
argentinas que por supuesto destacan la
noticia de la fiscalía que pidió
entonces 12 años de cárcel e
inhabilitación de cristina fernández de
kirchner puede ser por este caso llamado
vialidad donde supuestamente adjudicó a
adjudicó contratos pues a aliados y
amigos y también se enriqueció
ilegalmente indebidamente por toda esta
está esta trama de corrupción por la que
la fiscalía como recordamos entonces
pide 12 años de prisión vamos a ver si
entonces la ex presidenta va a prisión
actual vicepresidenta no exacto buenos
días raúl ésta es de momento solamente
la petición de la fiscalía recordemos de
asimismo lo titula la nación de hecho
este titular muy factual no el fiscal
pidió 12 años de cárcel e inhabilitación
de por vida a christina y en el
subtítulo destacan el fiscal lucian y la
consideró jefa de una asociación ilícita
para defraudar al estado y por otro lado
señala también la nación que el
presidente alberto fernández habló con
ella y la respaldo vamos ahora con el
clarín rosa sí que dice conmoción por el
pedido de 12 años de cárcel para
christina por corrupción una conmociona
que vemos en la imagen destacada no que
llevo de hecho tal y como nos señala
este periódico tanto a militantes que se
desplazaron para apoyar a la actual
vicepresidenta ex presidenta como a
opositores que fueron a protestar
digamos por el estas es acusación no por
este supuesto rol en esta causa de
corrupción y por otro lado también han
destaca clarín como el poder político y
el judicial se acusan mutuamente de
injerencia y también como decíamos que
esto todavía está a la mitad de este
proceso que el fallo llegará seguramente
antes de finales de año pero en todo
caso también se abrirían posibilidades
de apelaciones etcétera página 12
página 12 se posiciona abierta y
claramente del lado de cristina
fernández de kirchner y citan de hecho
su red diciendo es un pelado un pelotón
de fusilamiento mediático judicial y
seguido de esta cita va a una parte de
un texto de irina hauser y raúl kollmann
que dicen a pesar de la de la falta de
pruebas después de tres años de juicio y
los papelones cometidos con las
evidencias entre comillas tomadas de
otras causas los fiscales pidieron 12
años de cárcel y proscripción una fuerte
palabra no también en lugar de
inhabilitación dicen proscripción de por
vida para cristina kirchner bueno rosas
seguimos en nuestra región pero ya
cambiamos de tema vamos al país porque
destaca que el referendo de chile divide
a ese país ya a dos semanas no de su
celebración
exactamente contextualicemos recordemos
que este próximo 4 de septiembre chile
decide si aprueba o rechaza esta
propuesta de nueva constitución
elaborada por la asamblea constituyente
que recordemos surgió a raíz de esas
protestas masivas no que digamos
protagonizó chile en 2019
el país en un 78 por ciento aprobó que
se redactará una nueva constitución sin
embargo ahora que esta nueva
constitución está redactada y hay una
propuesta sobre la mesa se estima que
cerca del 50 por ciento de la población
rechazará este texto frente a un 40 por
ciento que votará para aprobar la hay
distintos estudios distintos sondeos las
cifras bailan un poco pero eso sí que
parece evidente que hay unos diez puntos
de diferencia entre el rechazo y el
apruebo con ventaja para el rechazo no y
nos dice el país que hay una brecha
generacional siendo los jóvenes más
propensos a apoyar este esta propuesta
de nueva carta magna también una brecha
urbana rural siendo santiago de chile-
digamos dónde se cuenta con una mayor
aprobación de esta constitución y
también una brecha de clase siendo las
clases altas y medias las más favorables
a votar por el apruebo por otro lado
también se ha vinculado mucho esta
constitución digamos con el mandato de
boris y es que de hecho se equipara
mucho el nivel de aprobación del
presidente con el porcentaje de
población que aprobaría este texto no y
recordemos también que la derecha
chilena se posicionó en contra de esta
constitución
digamos defendió el rechazo antes que
cualquier artículo estuviera redactado
porque no contaba ni con un tercio de
digamos representantes en esa asamblea
constituyente por lo que no tenían voz y
voto a la hora de digamos modificar o
influir en estas redacciones juegan ese
artículo lo puede encontrar entonces en
el país lo hizo rocío montes y también
en distintos medios internacionales rosa
se han hecho eco del acontecimiento y lo
intentan explicar como por ejemplo lo
hace la bbc exactamente y solamente para
pasar por encima resumirlo digamos que
tanto la bbc como otras medios de
comunicación señalan que las
discrepancias están más bien en la
interpretación que no en el texto que
está escrito negro sobre blanco y de
hecho hemos querido destacar un minuto
de un vídeo de la puya de este medio
independiente colombiano vinculado con
el espectador pero qué hacen en la
colaboración con la democracia abierta
de chile que precisamente mencionan
cuáles son
desmontan de hecho los principales bulos
que han circulado acerca de esta nueva
constitución de hecho no un momento en
que la desinformación está muy vinculada
con la manipulación vamos a verlo
se va a acabar chile
obvio que no es el rumor surgió porque
el primer artículo del nuevo borrador de
la constitución define a chile como un
estado plurinacional intercultural
regional y ecológico esto es muy
distinto a la anterior constitución que
decía que chile era un estado unitario y
democrático no pensaría que todo bien
con ese cambio simplemente el primer
artículo de la constitución está
describiendo la diversidad en chile en
normal héroes a todo todo tipo de
polémicas y mil chiles es integral que
van a cambiar el limón y ahora cuál será
la bandera de chile ya nos llamará chile
en que mejor dicho riis todos los
mapamundis para las clases de geografía
porque este país se acabó y que adiós
entendimos
cuidado la madera
estos miedos son infundados porque en
ningún lado la constitución dice es más
la misma constitución dice lo contrario
mi chile se va a desintegrar porque es
un estado único e indivisible ni se va a
cambiar el himno la bandera porque los
actuales seguirán siendo emblema
nacional y pues en todo el texto se
habla de chile chile chile chile chile
chile y chile no hay otro nombre para el
país y con chile chile y chile decidimos
entonces esta revista de prensa por el
legado y rosa muchísimas gracias nos
vemos mañana con más pasamos a saludar
nuestra primera invitada al día